[Music]
Stagnant water is piling up.  I
'm going to be a thermo day, it's a day of day.
Somehow a scary dream What
mother paint on my face. It was strong. It was strong -the
rice that I said yesterday and the
cleaning up
[Music]
Daddy Daddy is Ah.
Oh, oh, goo, what do you want to do when you get into the th direction? Write a diary Sabo, I'm going on a trip without a hotel
goo What
the hell is that?
[music]
I received my color,
me
[music]
and I was staring at
ana birds
ah ah ah
[music]
ah ah
hanapapa
[music]
me
car eh eh
[music]
me
ah ah ah
[music]
ahaan
ana my can you do
car
I thought I had to do something Somehow it wasn't good, but my
time was limited, but I made up my mind at that time.
And so, I set out on an aimless journey
Sweets pita drifting as I wish
Ren soy sauce is a leg
Waist and hmm
Ah, it's settled in the past
It's not good, is
n't it?
Isn't there a super old Tsurugi Yasusumi Megu
?  It doesn't make sense because I'm going alone to go to a book like that,
so I
'll help you
[music]
I'm home.
So to speak, the picture book is set up
What's the
matter?  I used a file to keep in touch with Japan.When things get too much, I can keep my
mouth shut
properly, so
don't worry,
I'll
go on a trip.
I
'm the
only one in my usual outfit, and I'm the only one who jumps out and
embarks on a destinationless journey
[music] To
a place I've never seen before
Why am I here?  I didn't have a place I wanted to go
to.
No, I'm not good at it, so I know why
[music]
Hey, you see, I'm always like
that When I join club activities, when I'm taking lessons, even when I'm taking
exams, but when I'm trying to take on a challenge
If I don't do it, what
should I do?If I fail, I'll regret it.
[Music]
Well
, I don't think that's a bad thing, but
I
hate it.  I
'm going out to play, hi
eh
[music
] I was there
acchan
bach
lee
ki
haa
If you count how many towns there are, it's a
leap of 1 million It's
the police who came anyway 2 I'm upset but
things seem good  I was really upset, or
rather, I think it was the school uniform that I had dropped
.
Maybe
I'll go to my house and say it's delicious Reese
.
what
ah
[Music]
Hahahaha What the hell is that?
But that's right
, in the end I couldn't find it
, and there were almost no days left,
so
I went in and found it. I can't
go to Antarctica.  That's
1 million yen, so keep working part-
time
I'll
go I'll tell everyone who said they couldn't get in, just
take a look After the exams, I decided that when I entered high school
[Music]
Antarctica Antarctica I don't think it's amazing The farthest corner of the earth
161 places Megu Shiro You know you're the two
Antarctica Antarctica  You
can't go to Antarctica with Toshiko, but you have 100 minutes.
Hey, that's
why people say I'm a weirdo, right?
Ahhh
[Music] It
's my bicycle, but that's
right.
I'm calling you teacher Because I want to ask you about money That's why tomotomo is a really good picture Matching is the only thing that I
notice is 4
things That's a lie Yeah, I won't surprise
you
Ah, I saw something I
wanted to talk to you about,
and I'm rooting for you.
But I can't do anything, and
when it comes down to it
, I get scared and quit  I think it's amazing that you can go and do your best with
all
your heart.  If you have nothing, tell me, then let's
go together
.
[Music]
I think that's normal I'm a
standing high school student, I'm going to school, and I have friends
.
I've come to you Then I believe you're serious I'm a
small
icebreaker Shirase
Resolutely
strong I
think that's why I
've
become strong
I think that's normal
I can't go
[Music] It's the
same as you ask, so forever
[Music]
I'm on a day every time
Kanda umbrella I'm going
on a trip
And Nail
Eguchi I
'm scared, but
I want to stop, but I pulled the earth
car [music] car It
may be meaningless, but
yeah
[music]
But from here
dai
me
yeah yeah
ni
me
mar
[music]
me
ni
[music]
tan
is right
oh ana
naonao 1 laa
r it's okay
adee
rar
me
[music]
[applause]
ni
dai
[music]
ni
[applause]
[music]
[laughter]
Good, good, go through the
equator, go through the
storm
, break the ice,
14,000 kilometers from Japan
, far farther than outer space, where
no one can
get close to,
how are you going to get there?
My
youth is starting to
move
[music]
Mr. Miyake here